found hadiya muhammad kaidea and her
daughter ayan sitting under a tree
waiting for rain
she was told some rain fell 400
kilometers from here so spent weeks
walking there with her goats but didn't
find any pasture so she walked back
most of her livestock died on the way
we depended on the livestock because we
would eat them and sell them but that is
no more our priority now is finding
water some people are drinking salt
water and it's giving them diarrhea we
need fresh water and food as now we
cannot eat or sell the livestock because
they are very weak
hadeer is one of more than 5 million
people affected by the drought in
somalia about a third of the population
many of them are herders who move around
with their animals following rains and
seeking pasture
camels and the goats can't eat this so
what's happened to most of the bushes
here after the last three rainy seasons
have failed and so this
is what's happened
to many of the animals and it's the
animals that enable people to live in
this dry environment that even at the
best of times
is difficult to survive in
the planes across which the herders move
with their animals are dry as far as the
eye can see
and it's the same in parts of the
country where people grow crops
two major rivers in the south have dried
up the surrounding areas used to be
known as the bread basket of somalia
people here say it's the first time this
has happened in living memory
near the dry river we met abdulrahman
noor ibrahim the river used to water his
crops
he's joined the hundreds of thousands of
people moving into camps after their
farms failed and animals died
he's 70 years old and lived through
several droughts including severe ones
in 2011 and 2017 but he says none have
been as bad as this
when small drought happened in these
areas in the past people fled to the
river for water but now the river is dry
all the way from the ethiopia border to
the sea
many of those displaced by the past
droughts are still in the camps unable
to restart their farms will restock
their herds the u.n says people in rural
somalia are among the least able to cope
with changing climate following 30 years
of conflict
climate change is directly related to
the drought that we are witnessing now
the frequency
of those climatic shock is now
increasing people who live in rural
areas their capacity to recover from
those shocks is extremely extremely
challenging because because of the
frequency
of these shocks back in the north the
herders whose animals have died are
moving into camps too
people have survived here herding
animals for thousands of years as the
droughts become more frequent and more
severe it's not clear if their way of
life can continue
or how they will survive
malcolm webb al jazeera galcio somalia